foreign
comes from Julie and the baby steps
millionaires group I'm saving 20 down to
buy a house in 2023 but this mortgage
rates uh keep me worried are you are we
really going to buy at six to seven
percent rate next year people's incomes
are not growing as much what are your
thoughts it will take longer to save
money for a down payment yeah and it is
hard I mean if you're seeing increases
of interest rates and you know it but
that the price of housing has kind of I
feel like it's definitely cooled off
studied yes has been increasing at the
same rate no no but the but the interest
rate is having people worried and so
Julie I mean just just looking at the
math we always talk about a down payment
of 10 to 20 so even if you wanted to get
into the housing market faster you could
just do save up 10 uh 20 is obviously a
wonderful goal but the 10 percent would
work but just making sure that your your
mortgage payment is no more than 25 of
your take-home pay that's the big part
of this equation and again a lot of
people fight us on that because it's
very conservative uh but here's the deal
like if half of your income is going to
a mortgage payment you're not going to
have a lot of money to go and enjoy and
to invest and to save your kids college
and to put extra on the house to pay it
down I mean it just limits your ability
so we don't want your your house your
mortgage payment to eat up so much of
your income so that's that's the
conservative approach that we take but
honestly it it works works and we just
took a call earlier from a guy who could
be looking at foreclosure because they
got in a house a little too soon the
payment's a little too much and so
walking to this really peacefully with
some wisdom even though it hurts because
you're looking at these interest rates
and you're going well even if the prices
stay the same a few interest rates
points higher could mean hundreds of
dollars more yeah and so like Rachel
said I would focus on that 25 parameter
of your after-tax take-home pay going
towards the Piti principal interest
taxes insurance and that gives you more
peace it's not necessarily about a
perfect down payment number and we're
not mad at you if you put down less than
20 percent
it's more about not having too much of
your world tied up in a mortgage payment
so I crunch some numbers using our
Ramsey mortgage calculator just to show
you what this looks like because the
numbers it's real and so let's say the
home price is 500 000 you want to put 20
down that's a hundred thousand down on a
15-year fixed well if the interest rate
was five percent your payment would be
38.47
when the interest rate goes to six
percent well now it jumps another 212
dollars to forty fifty nine if it jumps
to seven percent it jumps another two
hundred twenty dollars to 42.79 and
let's say it jumped to eight percent
it's another 227 at 4506 every month so
you can see from that five to eight
percent yeah it went from thirty eight
forty seven up to 4506. yeah it's a lot
from five to eight percent so that is a
real concern but here's the good news
you can always refinance later yep and
so if that if if that interest rate your
payment is within that 25 parameter go
for it you are ready to buy a house
regardless of the interest rate and when
the interest rates go down which they
inevitably Will based on history then
you can refinance at that lower rate and
a lot of people did that people now have
two or three percent interest rates yes
that's right uh which lowers their
payment so do not fear but I think it's
worth talking about the real estate
trends that we are seeing in 2023 and uh
this is based on our blog called 2023
real estate Trends what you need to know
we'll put the link in the show notes and
in the YouTube description for all of
you if you want to go check that out but
there's been lots of drama around buying
and selling a home in the last year
Rachel
here's some Market predictions and these
just give you an idea of what to expect
again they are predictions no one has a
crystal ball so never let these control
your housing decisions only your
personal situation and your finances
should do that so for 2023 the data is
pointing toward a slightly more stable
housing market not a crash we've been
saying this for I feel like a year now
since our real estate live live
streaming though because for a while it
was the housing prices were going crazy
and there was like 42 offers on any
house that was for sale in the in a
moment and people thought oh my gosh
this is turning into a bubble and now
it's the interest rates that have people
panicking that's right and this is all
because home prices are only driven by
the law of supply and demand so when
demand is greater than Supply home
prices don't tumble so today here's the
stats there's still a shortage of homes
for sale and lots of buyer demand that
is why home prices are still going up
but they're just going up at a slower
rate so leading into 2023 the median
home price reached over 366 thousand
dollars and that's only up two point 0.3
percent compared to a year ago yeah and
that growth
thanks but listen again the housing
market is not going to crash
so calm down and it still marks a
hundred and thirty consecutive months
that's over a decade of year-over-year
increases which is the longest running
streak they should win against world
record for that that's it that's it I
know so again it's not going to crash
and Freddie Mac actually predicts
overall home price growth in 2023 will
drop by point two percent point two yes
it's fairly drop that is yeah small
nothing to worry about and again it's
not a sign that the market is going to
crash so again calmer prices is directly
related to supply and demand and again
historically speaking there are more
homes for sale than people wanting to
buy and so that is that's the great
thing or I'm sorry more uh more buyers
out there it's been trailing behind them
that's right that's right yep so we're
we're seeing a slight uptick in Supply
and at the start of 2023 housing
inventory was up 10.2 percent year over
year and what that's still lower than it
was before the pandemic buyers should
have more options than they did the past
few years so again looking at buyer
demand last year the average mortgage
rate increased several months in a row
which lowered demand a bit again people
weren't going out and rushing to buy
homes as the interest rates kind of
ticked up which made it affordable for
other people because you could actually
go and negotiate the price which is
great but in January mortgage rates
dropped to the lowest that they've been
since September of 2022 and Freddie Mac
forecast rates to stay pretty steady
over the rest of this year so some
buyers who held off their plans because
of rising rates last year are likely to
return to the market in 2023. so in
other words what we're seeing here is
Supply is starting to meet in the middle
with demand but we still got a ways to
go so the bottom line we won't see home
prices plummet or spike in 2023 and the
market should feel steadier I think
that's good news so never sit and wait
for home prices or mortgage rates to
drop that's like timing the stock market
we would never tell you to do that it's
impossible to time the market so if
you're in good shape financially don't
wait to pull the trigger don't wait on
the interest rates to be the perfect
interest rate it's not going to do that
you can always refinance if the rates go
down
and so here's how you know if you're in
a good place you're debt free no
Consumer Debt whatsoever you have a
fully funded emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and then you have
that down payment to where the mortgage
payment won't eat up more than 25
percent of your monthly take-home pay on
a 15-year fixed rate mortgage and that
is some of our most controversial advice
I mean every time we say 15 year they're
like these guys are 25 these guys are
crazy and I'm like you know what's crazy
foreclosing on a home at 26 because you
felt pressured to jump into it to go and
buy well and the biggest thing too I
think is yes you don't want your you
don't want a massive mortgage payment
eating up your income because you want
to be able to do other things it's like
fun like fund retirement enjoy your life
give like do other things with your
money then just pay a mortgage payment
but also it is being debt free and
having an emergency fund in place please
have Savings in the bank yes when you go
to buy a home I mean home ownership it's
expensive things break things happen and
when you don't have money it turns ever
everything into a crisis I mean it you
live on the edge and it does something
to your I mean really your anxiety level
your stress level when you don't have
money saved in the bank for any day and
that's regardless of whether you're a
homeowner or not but especially if
you're looking to buy make sure you have
an emergency fund in place before you do
that yes we can't sit here complaining
about an interest rate going up a
percent which is 200 bucks instead of
going oh it's my car payment that's
killing me it's my credit card debt
that's killing 900 car payment clean up
the debt I'll give you some margin so if
you guys want help with the stuff we've
got tons of resources for you we've
created a hub at ramseysolutions.com
home buying and we can even connect you
with expert Pros to help you guide those
decisions give you confidence as you
step into the largest purchase of your
life